foreign
did you think he was going to kill you
if you want to hurt somebody you can
hurt me I said if you're going to stab
me you better stab me now until before
this bus stops
a man threatened with a knife on an RTC
bus by now accused killer speaking
exclusively with our 8 news now
investigators and that passenger and the
bus driver were able to get help but as
we're eight news now investigators have
uncovered that simply was not enough the
suspect later deemed low risk and
released from custody without having to
pay any bail 10 days later he was booked
for murder 8 news now investigator David
charns with that man's story finding out
the man accused of threatening him
allegedly murdered another passenger
David Denise and Brian the 87
investigators obtaining this
surveillance video which police say
shows Aaron Cole right there in the
middle standing up with a knife in his
hand and then threatening threatening
that is the passenger you see there sort
of the orange in this video Days Later
Cole would face a new charge of murder
and that's the thing that you have to
live with the reality of like that could
have been you Abraham Guerrero says he's
lucky to be alive the bus arrives and I
get on there that ride on February 16th
was normal until Guerrero says another
passenger started yelling at a woman and
her children so I took initiative and
said look man you need to calm down you
need to stop disrespecting her in front
of her children she hasn't done anything
to you
that's Guerrero's voice in this
surveillance video
I know that other Rider 59 year old
Aaron Cole then stands up and pulls a
knife Guerrero steps back as other
passengers move away what was your
reaction when you saw that knife
I said oh damn what did I just do I have
my backpack and if he came lunging at me
I could use it as a as a as a shield
video shows the driver stopping the bus
he then alerts dispatchers and waits for
police do you think you prevented a
murder on the bus of course of course
after you know seeing the way he reacted
they didn't take anything to get him to
react to and get any officers would
arrest Cole who they would learn served
23 years in a Texas prison for attempted
murder but a few days after this threat
a Las Vegas judge released coal without
having him pay any Veil Cole's pre-trial
risk assessment pieces of paper to
inform judges of an offender's potential
risk to reoffend deeming him low risk
nobody's gonna pull out a knife if
they're not going to act on it ten days
later police say Aaron Cole was back on
the bus when he got into an argument
with 30-year-old Dominique Lucas this
time detectives say he acted on his
anger Cole accused of stabbing Lucas 33
times and it never happened now Guerrero
a construction worker and house cleaner
whose only option is to take the bus
says he he could have been Cole's victim
you feel trapped when he pulled the
knife on me you know it's
it's just you and him and whoever else
is on the bus Guerrero made it off the
bus alive but he now questions his
safety every ride and he wonders why the
man suspected of threatening violence
never know who's going to get on the bus
made it back on board armed with a knife
only to face new charges at the end of
the day it's very sad that someone had
to lose their life because of this you
know
because of what what happened
Aaron Cole has pleaded not guilty and he
did decline our interview request we're
bringing you this story the same day
that sources confirmed to the 8 news now
investigators a bus Supervisor was
stabbed just last week this happened
last Monday at the Bonville Transit
Center downtown a man stabbing that bus
supervisor quickly arrested but no
public agency said anything about this
until we reported this today supervisor
works for one of the companies RTC
contracts with to provide us bus service
spokesperson for that company praising
the supervisor for his actions saying
he's recovering well I'm David charns
eight news now